[Music]
study you're with me on this one right
oh your strength gives me strength
when the movie was gonna come out we had
no no idea what it was gonna be is it is
a comedy is it an action picture is it
an adventure about all of it none of it
I can still hear Rachel going oh no
they're going to confiscate our Equity
cards
what does that even mean did we do it
wrong did we chew up the scenery too
much yeah I know I did but I had a lot
of pruvit shots in it we rode our own
camels we wielded our weapons we fought
one another we ran around in the heat of
the desert of war zazat in Morocco and
all of that gave an authenticity to the
movie that I think made it more globally
appealing